hi vanessa
hello
thank you so much for being here how
comfortable are you
sitting so close to stephen right now
well i don't feel that uncomfortable
it's not like he's dangerous i'm here to
support alina
okay
when you first met stephen what
attracted you to him initially
i was going through a bit of a faith
crisis
i i grew up lds as well
and
um
along came stephen and he was really
nice
and how long did you two date
only like three or four months okay
why did you two break up
well steven was
fronting as you know a faithful man who
wanted to be in a monogamous
relationship
and then he was gonna go to russia for
two months i just told him he can date
other girls
but please don't go all the way
so he comes back from russia and i was
his girlfriend but he confessed to me
that while he was in russia he had had
sex with three girls
someone
and
of course that broke my heart i cried
wow
vanessa i'd like for you to talk
directly to elena what do you think she
should do
the things that i'm hearing how he has
nine girls he's been sp he's spoken to
that
he
wants to have a threesome why is he
trying to convince her to do this alina
who has never been with anybody else
alina who is young and sacrificing so
much to be with him
like i know a divorce is so difficult
and you've made these vows to him
but i don't think he's going to change
if anything i would say he's gotten
worse appreciate you being so respectful
to me and care about my feelings
i can't like just
walk away
um
i have a hope that he loves me
enough to
be able to change
he hurt both of you i don't think he's
gonna change i think that vanessa's
right stephen you're not a freak or
anything but it's not fair to
you know have one foot in the door and
one foot out the door
that's kind of funny coming from someone
who just abandoned their husband
i didn't abandon my husband i went to
get my son surgery in the u.s
i'm fully invested
no you're not you're talking to nine
different women you're not invested in
anything
um
it was
a fleeting moment of weakness nine
fleeting moments of weakness
well over a couple of days over how many
years because the same thing happened
whether you had sex with three women in
russia please i i can't take the vote
[Music]
you